finish
yeah what uh what are you doing my
fatality tugging at my neck is your
fatality no I'm going to rip your head
off with your bare hands yes not even
both your hands just one hand it looks
cooler with one hand pull your head off
and your spine still attached to it okay
you're telling me you're gonna rip my
head off with one hand and my spine
the thing that's fused to every other
bone in my body with no leverage we just
shut up let me rip your head and spine
out of your body in silence please I'm
not stopping you it's just you know the
laws of physics the fact that I made of
matter you okay back there buddy I can
feel it's loosening no yeah yeah it's
wholly loosening oh no no no no no no
here look I'll sit down you get behind
me bend your knees engage the core and
on three I'll push my body away from you
you lifted in the opposite direction
okay okay
one two three
finally oh oh that felt good you are one
hell of a chiropractor dammit you know
my back has been killing me ever since
you froze me and punched me back to room
temperature but now it feels great hmm
oh hey come on buddy
mmm here let me let me help you out I'll
show you what you're doing wrong oh
really
yeah look okay I'll just waver over here
like I'm pretty much dead that's great
Johnny Cage Weems yeah it's way easier
when you just punch it off Fritz have
too nice